hi guys I'm crashing telling you I was
at WonderCon all day yesterday and then
I had to go to a birthday and I woke up
incredibly sick very sick I'm sure you
guys can tell by my face and voice no I
don't hear I'm sorry I'm sorry the list
invitation the show must go on
you never stop recording evil hyenas
they have never stopped recording it's
just too good to be bad trailer Terry I
hope they release at least six more
injustice trailers right now amen
just show me a whole movie before we get
the footage watch damn good to be bad
thirteenth trailer right something like
that
here we go like so on Oh
gorilla grodd
[Music]
and
Oh No Oh flash hider allegorize out
there fire my babe oh my babe yeah he's
a crucible take a ninja oh cool
drop it let's put you on our cap people
all night ah 0 0 K 0 finally a shot to
be a nightmare cried there : scream whoa
goddamn
whoa looks like a bane do you owe
dad
Oh here at the hall
big character that was pretty cool that
was pretty cool
Oh feeling it everybody we know starting
oh oh dear holy crap I enjoy that a lot
like we got the girls see how all the
girls finds up with this one so you know
villains scarecrow is just huge like in
they look like a complete like monster
in this one character was like the
xenomorph Captain Cold was like sub-zero
yep
Gorilla Grodd is like what the guy with
Goro
he's like a leather face actually you're
doing them hope movers and it feels more
like Mortal Kombat than yeah I got it
like up in every time that they meet
this that's really cool it's really cool
it was really good compared to the last
ones and stuff like you would just see
like the normal characters basically
like how low you would tomb in any other
game that they would be in and stuff
with this one they just really put on
that mortal kombat like scary characters
where it's like you got to get like
leather faces oh yeah it's like and I
think in the DCE you I wonder if this is
somehow way I think at a DC Universe
right now people really love Batman
still and people run the flash show you
get Captain Cold & Gorilla Grodd who are
pretty prominent characters in the flash
show yeah and you get scarecrow and bait
or pretty prominent villains one of the
Batman rogue gallery I mean it is the
best about like if you're watching that
show you see them in there you're like
oh man actually could really characters
see how they're like switching it from
that to this and Captain Cold like he
looks really badass in this one like at
first you just think like okay it's just
a regular dude with a freeze gun like
I'm gonna be cool well like yeah there's
like that thing different
gun and salsa but that one's probably
going to be like you know if you pick
sub-zero constantly and more comedy yeah
your character to be I wonder how the
Scarecrow character works in here
because he's a human being
he's Jonathan crane but they seem like a
creatures I don't know if they're hiding
him was it the gas the toxin whatever he
releases to make you think you're seeing
a monster is that what it looks like
when you're fighting him or is that like
how scary was having yeah as anyone was
that where they brought from the Arkham
night where you chug antic yeah like I'm
so glad I brought that special move that
you use where he's like [ __ ] x-ray
move master has an x-ray move it was
really really bad Ansel today but it's
coming out next time I'm going to have a
right when it drops you're going to come
over to my house and just tell me the
characters I'm not to beat you right now
Oh tickets at all this is all I want to
do this video for is just to know what
I'm going to beat you dude how else the
character I'm going to be Batman alright
and I'm gonna do it I'm gonna be poison
ivy
how are you like I'm poison ivy so bad
on that she's hot I'm gonna have to whip
your ass a captain Cole because I will
be honest with sub-zero no that's gonna
be definitely record uh how can you talk
to a dying man
this way toting that they'll beat you at
a bang just for coming up realize it was
your see who easily see you Rocky
okay ma'am I will destroy her or what
you did doing it is I will break you
Batman he still has that voice for this
man that's a very I feel it's gonna have
to be putting on have to be chose me
break your back this is that smack talk
you've ever done knowing it is hey hey
you guys
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects
Tony he's crazy on Instagram crazy
own instant Graham then he helped out
with our sketch Greg and Anita revealed
go over there now on
camera what I want to break tension
upset I get naked and hug the crew yeah
like I thought that was awkward at first
but after like you know so many times I
come over your house and do the same
thing over and over again like it can't
get just to it sometimes yeah we don't
even film we just just get naked to come
over all of us bring over my camera
women and he goes cut
I never said bring your camera equipment
I just wanna really tag nits in giant
letters saying brain